sur ce qui est la question du management
il me semble qu'il y aurait 2 2 angles
d'attaqué que l'on pourrait prendre
et en dix minutes ils sont très
difficiles à résumer on ne peut
comprendre l'évolution du management que
si on la situe en relativement longue
période et que l'on ne regarde pas
simplement ce qui s'est passé là
rapidement et mais en même temps comme
nous vivons une période de crise cette
période de crise a un impact sur le
management réel et la question aussi de
se dire est ce que cet impact va être
durable c'est à dire est-ce qui a émergé
pendant cette crise pour continuer après
où est ce qu'on va revenir aux
situations anciennes
alors si je voulais faire une rapide
synthèse
je dirais ceci je devais m'intéressait
lac au secteur marchand pas au secteur
administratif
après on pourra parler des différences
avec le secteur administratif mais dans
le secteur marchand la la la période qui
va jusqu'à au début de la crise parce
qu'elle change des choses et
probablement eu une période dans
laquelle les entreprises ont atteint une
forme d'apogée en matière bureaucratique
c'est à dire que toute la période qui va
on va dire super de la fin des années 80
aux années 2020 a été une période qui
petit à petit a vu se renforcer les très
bureaucratique dans la gestion même
quotidienne des entreprises
alors on pourrait rapidement comprendre
pourquoi parce que à l'issue de la
deuxième guerre mondiale jusque pendant
toute cette période qu'on a appelé les
trente glorieuses on a bâti des
organisations qui étaient forme d'avant
talmant endogène c'est à dire bien plus
tourné vers elle même qu'elle n'était
tournée vers leurs marchés
ces organisations endogène par
définition sont très protectrices pour
celles qui travaillent à l'intérieur de
ces organisations
même si elles ne produisent pas des
biens et des services d'extrême qualité
les produisent à des coûts élevés peu
importe ensuite les marchés se sont
ouverts suite aux différents chocs
pétroliers etc et les entreprises ont eu
à faire face à une question qui est une
apparence une quadrature du cercle
petit à petit la concurrence aidant
elles ont fait face à des clients qui
voulaient plus pour moi et pour résoudre
cette contradiction des clients qui
veulent plus pour moi quelle a été la
façon d'y répondre
quelle a été la variable d'ajustement ça
a été le management et l'organisation du
travail et donc on a essayé de passer
d'organisation verticaliser en silo
extrêmement protectrice encore une fois
parce qu'ils travaillaient à des
organisations beaucoup plus transversale
mais qui sont quand même temps d
organisation beaucoup plus confrontation
elle pourrait-on dire
la conséquence de ce 1 s'est vu par les
salariés est vécue en particulier par
les cadres on a des protéger le travail
alors je dis pas l'emploi je dis bien le
travail au sens coup je parle ici des
conditions du travail et pourquoi on a
des protégés cry parce que au lieu que
les gens de travail de façon
relativement en paix dans leur
silhouette d'un coup d'un seul on a
introduit de la coopération qui est un
mot à connotation extrêmement positif
mais enfin qui amène les gens dans des
situations de dépendance réciproque et
toutes les études que nous avons
montrent que la dépendance est quelque
chose qui pose problème et la riposte
des salariés qu'ils appellent une
riposte pensée qui est ce qui s'est
passé dans les faits a été à partir de
là les phénomène de désengagement du
travail et les entreprises face à ces
phénomènes de désengagement du travail
qui sort qui est indécent engagement
émotionnel beaucoup plus comme désengage
40 ans alors même qu'elle avait besoin
de l'engagement de leurs salariés pour
faire face à la concurrence comme je le
disais comment ils ont elle riposté
elles ont riposté par la coercition
alors moi je sais que chaque fois que je
parle de coercition tout le monde lève
les bras au ciel en disant comment
comment est ce possible de parler de
coercition dans les entreprises c'est
pas possible
vous exagérez je fais quoi peu importe
ce que j'appelle la coercition sait on a
essayé de contrôler au plus juste non
seulement ce que font les gens mais
comment il le faut et on l'a fait à
travers ce qu'on appelle les outils de
management les systèmes de reporting les
indicateurs de performance les process
et c'est que l'on à multiplier à l'envi
et cetera le problème c'est que le
résultat obtenu a été exactement inverse
du résultat recherché
plus on multiplie tous ces indicateurs
tous ces procès toutes ces normes ses
procédures et caetera et moi il est
possible de fonctionnaires les
appliquant et donc finalement pour que
ça marche il a fallu que ceux qui sont
chargés de les appliquer acceptent de ne
pas appliquer ceux ci d'appliquer cela
de contourner ceci ou cela et c est donc
dans le fond au lieu de contrôler bien
ce que font les gens on a plus ou moins
perdu le contrôle que l'on pouvait à
avoir précédemment sur le fonctionnement
des organisations
c'est donc en multipliant les règles
bureaucratiques
on a perdu le contrôle des organisations
et avant la crise qu vide
je crois que l'un était là avec une
interrogation de la part des peut-être
pas des chefs d'entreprise qui avait
relativement délaissé le domaine de
l'organisation pour différentes raisons
mais les drh en particulier étaient dans
cette situation où il disait d'eux mêmes
et si on continue comme ça on va dans le
mur alors la deuxième partie ce serait
de dire qu'est ce que la crise que nous
vivons a changé ici je voudrais dire une
petit point d'or et de méthode
moi je vais pas vous parler de mes
sentiments sur ce que ça a changé mais
avec deux de mes collègues nous avons
conduit une étude qui s'est étalée du
mois de mars au mois de septembre 2020
auprès de neuf organisations cette
entreprise une grande administration
publique et de collectivités une grosse
collectivité territoriale et nous avons
cherché à comprendre qu'ils avaient et
comment avait été géré cette crise que
ça qui soit en même temps qu'il y avait
le confinement et que ça soit dans le
télétravail ou dans le travail
présentiel
et là on a vu apparaître des phénomènes
qui sont des phénomènes qui redistribue
les cartes
parce que si on pose la question de
façon directe qui a géré la crise qui la
gérait concrètement parlant
eh bien il ya deux acteurs qui l'ont
gérée principalement principalement même
si je caricature peu dans le petit laps
de temps de dix minutes que vous avez
donnée mais la crise a été gérée d'abord
par les dirigeants mais les dirigeants
eux-mêmes pour une raison c'est que ils
ont lu c'est eux qui ont eu à appliquer
les directives gouvernementales qui ont
été parfois changeantes
c'était pas toujours très facile c'est
eux qui ont eu à décider ça ne pouvait
certes et leur niveau les compensations
financières que l'on pouvait donner aux
salariés et ce qui d'ailleurs nous a
amené à une surprise dans études que
nous avons menées ces cas une exception
près d'une entreprise que bien sûr je ne
citerai pas les organisations syndicales
que nous interview vion disait le patron
notre dirigeant a tenu ses promesses
il a fait ce qu'il avait dit qu'il
ferait et nous sommes contents des
vivres dans cette entreprise
alors ça fait 40 ans que je fais des
études sur les entreprises c'est à peu
près la première fois que j'entends des
syndicalistes unanimes pour dire quelque
chose comme ça donc c'était vraiment une
surprise mais en face de ses dirigeants
ceux qui ont géré la crise c'est ce qui
était jusque là dans certains produits
les oubliés du management c'est-à-dire
l'encadrement de proximité ce que
j'appelle la paire de vans de proximité
c'est ceux qui gèrent directement les
études que ça soit en présentiel ou que
ça soit en télétravail et cet
encadrement de proximité
quelles que soient les activités de
biens ou de services
cet encadrement de proximité s'est vu
confier pendant toute la crise et ça
continue deux missions et ça va
recommencer si nous sommes confinés à
nouveau d'ici la fin de la semaine où je
sais pas quand la première mission a été
d'assurer la continuation de l'activité
et ça c'était quelque chose de très
important par définition pour les
entreprises et la deuxième mission qui
se sont vus confier c'est une mission de
s'occuper des personnes fragiles
c'est à dire de ceux qui parmi les
salariés étaient considérés comme
pouvant poser problème les personnes
seules
les personnes ayant des problèmes de
santé
ce qui veut dire qu'on a demandé à cet
encadrement de proximité à la fois de
gérer la continuation de l'activité et
de gérer en même temps le confinement
lorsqu'il y avait confinement et de ce
point de vue là il est remarquable de
remarquer une chose de remarquable de
remarquer il est remarquable d'observer
une chose c'est que pour arriver à
assurer cette continuation de l'activité
cet encadrement de proximité à pratiquer
ce que l'on appelle en sociologie la
désobéissance organisationnel c'est à
dire qu'il était dans ces situations de
crise puisqu'on parle ici d'un
management de crise il était impossible
et je vais faire le lien entre les deux
parties sur lesquels je me suis appuyé
il était impossible d'assurer la
continuation de l'activité dans de
bonnes conditions
si on suivait tout ce fatras
bureaucratique de process de normes de
procédure qui avait été émise par des
fonctions support qui sont au niveau des
sièges et qui effectivement ne
connaissez pas bien les impératifs de la
continuation de l'activité doc
c'est cet encadrement de proximité s'est
autonomisée véritablement de façon forte
à pratiquer de la désobéissance
organisationnel que bien sûr personne ne
lui a reproché on a même félicité ses
sacs a permis effectivement que
l'activité continue et le point le
double point qui est aujourd'hui
intéressant et sur lequel il ya une
double point d'interrogation même un
triple point d'interrogation durant
cette période on a peu vu se manifester
ce qu'on appelle l'encadrement
intermédiaire
cet encadrement intermédiaire est resté
relativement absents dans la gestion de
cette crise et aujourd'hui il va avoir
un problème de repositionnement de
savoir comment il peut se repositionner
dans le fonctionnement quotidien de
l'entreprise et d'autre part on assiste
à une mise en cause de ce que j'ai
appelé tout à l'heure les fonctions
supports sièges qui sont celles qui sont
qu'ils sont lésés maîtrise de ce que
j'appelle le fatras bureaucratiques ou
m'excuserai d'utiliser cette expression
parce qu'on s'est rendu compte que
lorsque l'encadrement de proximité
s'autonomiser par rapport à ce fatras
bureaucratique
ça marchait bien et même ça marche et
lieux et donc la question qui est
aujourd'hui posée aux entreprises et je
puis vous dire sans citer de noms que
certaines ont déjà plusieurs décisions
c'est qu'est ce que l'on va faire par
rapport à ses fonctions la décision
étant généralement d'en réduire
drastiquement le nombre et les
compétences puisqu'on sait que toutes
les bureaucraties si on les laisse à
l'état dans lequel elles sont trouveront
toujours de quoi s'occuper et donc on ne
pourra réduire cette bureaucratie
envahissante dans le secteur marchand
que si effectivement on lui réduit ses
moyens d'envoyer autonomie de
l'internement de proximité est ce qu'on
la garde cette autonomie ce qui
introduit dans le management de la
question de la confiance
repositionnement de l'encadrement
intermédiaire
comment va-t-il arriver à se positionner
par rapport à l'encadrement de proximité
plus autonomes et mis en cause des
fonctions support siège et de la réelle
utilité par rapport au fonctionnement de
l'organisation
voilà quelques leçons que l'on peut
tirer merci beaucoup monsieur de 7,2
cette ouverture il ya déjà beaucoup de
questions sous jacentes pour n'y
reviendra on va s'intéresser au droit du
travail si vous voulez avec monsieur
wade je vous donne la parole
merci monsieur le président on me dit
que je partage
99% des idées émises par mon collègue du
puits ce qui est rare mon cher collègue
entre les sociologues et juristes qui se
regardent parfois avec quelques
difficultés
alors juste un point on va parler du but
du passé ont fait jamais table rase y'a
jamais d'événements qui tombent par
hasard
et là c'est la séquence émotion certains
d'entre nous ici on est rooté dylan en
66 et si vous relisez dylan aujourd'hui
ça fait drôle
pères et mères votre autorité c'est fini
ministres députés dégager de ce mur
parce que nous allons venir la jeunesse
et puis un an après il ya eu jacques
dutronc et moi et moi et moi
en un mot les phénomènes macro sociaux
dont on parle aujourd'hui ils sont pas
nées de la crise et du télétravail
la société d'individus les droits de la
personne au travail ça remonte bien
avant la crise bien avant la crise et
l'idée que je pourrais développer devant
vous dans le temps qui lui est imparti
c'est que et là je suis très
culpabiliser parce que je vais pas très
fier de ce que je vous expliquais mais
vous verrez ma conclusion que le juriste
ne baisse jamais les armes c'est que
figurez vous et je ne pense pas que mon
collègue du puy me désavouera que les
entreprises ont beaucoup changé beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup changé depuis 30 ans
les salariés ont beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup changé juste un chiffre qui est
très parlant parce qu'on parlera des
générations y auquel on prête plein de
défauts et de qualité qui peut être n'en
sont pas autant de défauts et de qualité
il ya un continuum assez exceptionnel
mais grosso modo en 1920 il y avait 2 %
de jeunes qui avaient le bac aujourd'hui
niveau bac cesse plus 110 % aux niveaux
bas que ce en déboursant que chan train
de vous dire c'est que le fonctionnement
de l'institution
le logiciel de nos décideurs n'a pas
encore pleinement intégrer la révolution
silencieuse qui est en cours depuis 30
ans en france et je le ferai
vous devinez monsieur le président de
parti sans ça tout le monde va être
perdu je vais vous expliquer sur quoi le
droit du travail est encore fondées
encore aujourd'hui notre code du travail
est fondé sur ce paradigme que je vous
décrire en quatre points et puis dans
une seconde partie toujours en 4 points
jouent expliquerait pourquoi là on est
on est en difficulté et évidemment et je
veux dire que quand on lit le code du
travail sur temps et lieu de travail sur
torreilles de travail surtout au lieu de
travail et qu'on voit que quatre
millions de personnes travaillent à leur
domicile
et quand un accord interprofessionnel
sens a dit que au bureau et au domicile
c'est pareil bon on va s'apercevoir que
le domicile n'est pas un bureau que le
bureau n'est pas un domicile
en clair ça ne tient plus par quoi
va-t-on remplacé alors premièrement je
vous rappelle que et je ne parle pas du
passé entre nous bien je ne parle pas du
passé je parle d'aujourd'hui du code du
travail 2021 je vous parle pas du code
du travail de léon blum sur quoi s'est
fondé ce que du travail
alors là c'est la séquence émotion aussi
c'est pour les plus de 50 ans ce que les
moins de vingt ans ne peuvent pas
connaître
c'est il faut jamais perdre de vue que
toute la société était sur un mode
vertical
en un mot il va pas que l'entreprise qui
était subordonnée d'accord il y avait la
puissance paternelle
j'ai été éduqué par un pulsar ne mordent
la république il avait quatre classes et
personne n'osait élever la voix un
hameau de puisque chez entre vous
expliquer c'est que depuis tout petit
j'ai été formaté pour être subordonnée
dans la famille à l'école j'avais eu des
maîtres dont la parole ne pouvait pas
être remise en cause c'était
inconcevable
j'étais parfaitement formatés paris
l'osier entreprise éco mon supérieur
hiérarchique me disent elles citons
supérieur hiérarchique
je mettais à genoux sans doute et je
disais vous êtes forcément plus beau
plus intelligent plus performant hélas
si vous dites ça des managers
d'aujourd'hui il éclate en sanglots
parce que les rapports entre l'autorité
les managers sont pas exactement les
mêmes j'y reviendrai alors quels sont
les quatre affirmation rapidement pour
andré lescure 1 ce modèle qui est celui
de 2021 j'assistais pas un modèle
dépassé le code du travail est fondée là
dessus
tout d'abord il été conçue sur un modèle
qui était ce qu'on ne reproche pas un
code la date de sa naissance
le code du travail est né en mai mais en
même temps que la révolution
industrielle donc la révolution
industrielle
c'est évidemment la reine pour
l'essentiel un coup de louche une
révolution militaro industriel le modèle
de la ford t noir et donc si vous
rappeler le modèle de charlie chaplin
est ce que c'était un homme - robots
charlie chaplin a caricaturé mais
c'était plutôt un robot en un mot le
travailleur du code du travail de 1936
c'était quelqu'un qui était subordonnée
et plus il était subordonnée plus l'été
productif à chacune ses seins fermes de
ces affirmations vous pourrez renvoyé
aujourd'hui est ce qu'aujourd'hui on
fait beau c'est un travailleur du savoir
plus les subordonnés plus productif on
sent que ça ne tourne plus ce système là
sur bon en un mot ce modèle là a été
d'une efficacité exceptionnelle pour
reproduire la ford-t noir c'est ce qu'a
fait aussi trente glorieuses
il nous faut pas jeter le bébé avec
l'eau du bain encore en un mot si notre
croissance est aussi forte c'est que ce
système de production
je vais y revenir un instant a été d'une
efficacité économique considérable
deuxième idée
c'est j'insiste il ya une organisation
qui est très prévenante parce que
boileau aurait fait un article dans
l'encyclopédie exceptionnel disant que
finalement les entreprises du 20e siècle
20e siècle début milieu c'est finalement
ce que j'avais dit à propos du théâtre
unité de temps de lieu et d'action
le temps la sirène le lieu là
l'entreprise éclaire au mur et l'action
la chaîne vous aurez compris que ce mode
organisationnel génère forcément une
très fort subordination c'est sur une
chaîne il manque une personne la chaîne
s'arrête en un mot tout va bien peu de
tout et decker d'accord 3 très important
très très important sur tous les enfants
qui ont un portable ce qui est fréquent
par les temps qui courent la loi de la
pesanteur qui joue rappel ne figure dans
aucun code et l'interdît physiquement
toute exportation du twr du travail chez
soi ou en dehors l'usaid il était
physiquement impossible à charlie
chaplin de dire oh j'ai pas terminé mais
fort de thé noir jaune emmené deux ou
trois la maison j'espère qu'à chaque
fois vous voyez ce que je veux dire par
rapport au mode actuel en amour il ne
s'était pas illégal c'était physiquement
je m'aime stakhanov mais pas dire je
vais terminer trois tonnes de charbon à
la maison et puis bien sûr et là je il
parle sous l'autorité de mon collègue
c'était le compromis fordiste et là je
peux vous dire que compromis fordiste
moi qui fais court j'ai peut-être un
avantage compétitif sur beaucoup de
personnes ici c'est que ça fait 35 ans
que je vois des jeunes de 20 ans devant
moi et je peux vous dire que le produit
a changé mais il a beaucoup changé
il a beaucoup beaucoup changé exemple
aujourd'hui je vais cours
j'ai la chance de faire des cours dans
des grandes écoles voisines et bien
quand vous dites à un jeune talent comme
on l'appelle d'entreprise sorbonne
sciences po je parle des trois écoles je
parlerai après des d'autres écoles
qu'ils ont pu et bien quand vous leur
dites tu vas entrer dans une grande
entreprise pétrolière
la réponse est non et on leur dit mais
tu sais ce qu'est que la convention
collective du pétrole c'est la meilleure
convention collective de france il dit
mais se sépare les questions que je suis
en train de vous dire c'est que le
compromis fordiste l'employeur disant je
te donne la stabilité de l'emploi
je t'augmente et salaires et vous les
syndicats vous me cherchez pas sur
l'aspect politique de la subordination
d'accord et deuxièmement vos conditions
de travail c'est les risques du métier
eh bien ça ça super bien marché
mais au prix décernés été négative dont
on mesure aujourd'hui l'enjeu d'accord
et je ne reproche pas à mon grand père
d'avoir fait ce qu'il a fait ça va
souvent ne reproche pas à son grand-père
les fautes qui sont les nôtres
aujourd'hui conclusions de ces quatre
j'insiste beaucoup ce que je vais vous
décrire la c est donc surtout s'il vous
plaît quand je lis parfois que le droit
du travail va est mort j'ai envie de
dire restent polis parce que la
subordination que je sache ne pas
disparu demandez à des salariés d'un
centre d'appels demandé à des vendeuses
dont surtout ne disons pas que avec le
passage vous voyez ma transition avec la
cité numérique
et bien ça y est le droit au travail a
pu subordination je pense même on en
parle si vous voulez après que les
nouvelles technologies c'est pas le surf
n'est aux californiens les nouvelles
technologies c'est la polarisation de
société les travailleurs intellectuels
comme moi ce deviennent plus autonomes
ils travaillent quand ils veulent où ils
veulent en revanche les déjà subordonnés
je pense aux routiers les routiers
s'éteint c'est un métier extrêmement
difficile mais c'était un métier de
liberté je m'arrêtais dans le restaurant
que je voulais dans l'hôtel que je
voulais j'avais mes habitudes
aujourd'hui les routiers ont un gps qui
les surveillent à 3 mètres près des
travaux qui étaient assez autonomes sont
devenus sur subordonnés alors que nous
apporte la révolution de l'immatériel
ben si vous laissez c'est pour ça que je
remercie ses 19 de l'électrochoc
organisationnel qui vous a fait
connaître le 16 mars 2020 combien
d'entre nous aurait dit ici un an que la
france serait passé en travail à
domicile etc internet aurait tenus je
vous laisse imaginer une seconde si
internet avait planté si les télécoms
avait planté une seconde et c'était une
possibilité mais voilà ce que je vous
expliquais pour non encore trois minutes
si vous permettez monsieur le président
c'est la chose suivante c'est que ce
modèle-là était parfait pour dupliquer
pour reproduire
or aujourd'hui pour un ingénieur
dupliquer et reproduire dans un service
r d c'est pas ce qu'on lui demande
on lui demandait de créatifs d'accord de
sortir de ces zones de confort et quels
sont ces quatre caractéristiques
premièrement c'est l'ubiquité du travail
intellectuel alors ne me dit pas comme
ceux qui voient la roche de ronsard
c'est entièrement nouveau les gens qui
travaillent à distance
si vous aimez rousseau moi je n'aime pas
mais on fait avec et bien rousseau
disait je n'ai jamais pu travailler à
mon bureau c'est la nuit pendant mes
insomnies que je travaille dans mon
cerveau en un mot que les travailleurs
intellectuels et plus travailler partout
ça n'a rien de très nouveau
les nouvelles technologies ont facilité
le travail à distance
mais depuis tout temps et du travail à
distance premièrement donc
et là je fais le refrain en forme de
cruelles dépression j'ouvre mon code et
je vois des gens travailler partout
lorient secondaire dans leur voiture sur
les dans les aéroports et on me dit au
temps et lieu de travail au temps et
lieu de travail autant il le travail
qu'elle est en 2021 le temps de travail
peut-on calcul à la minute près ce
qu'exige le code
quel est le lieu de travail yat-il
encore demain un lieu de travail
première idée donc cette
dématérialisation conduit à levi puis tu
es et une remise en cause de ce qu'on
savait sur temps et lieu de travail
deuxièmement je n'y reviens pas je
l'expliqué la création exige de
l'autonomie la subordination et là c'est
pas l'aspect être sympa c'est pas
l'aspect la subordination c'est terrible
là je parle simplement de productivité
les étudiants tech forme endroit pas
rien y compris ceux de mon master
développement surhumaine droit social on
leur demande pas de recracher le code
parce que le code tout le monde là et
sur internet je sais comment faire une
procédant essentiellement on leur
demande d'être créatif de répondre
rapidement à des questions et de ce
point de vue là la subornation et contre
productive en un mot c'est que je ne
conteste pas en soi la sueur relation
c'est ça ne fonctionne pas toujours
toujours avec les travailleurs du savoir
troisièmement là c'est encore une autre
séquence je suis lorrain
du côté où savez de pont-à-mousson
pompeux enfin des zones industrielles où
on savait ce que c'était que travail et
les risques du métier
qu'est ce qui faisait la fierté des
métallos rappelez vous il est une pièce
il circulait ses camarades arrivés et
ils disaient c'est nickel chrome
on était fier de ce qu'on faisait même
si c'est un boulot de reproduire un rail
le rail il était nickel chrome et dans
votre questionnaire il ya la santé au
travail
et là je vous parlais d'un problème
personnel
crush que je crois qu'on partagera tout
si on les travaux intellectuels combien
d'entre vous qu'on leur demande un
dossier une étude envoie l'étude en
disant c'est nickel chrome
y a rien à ajouter si c'est votre cas
donnez moi votre adresse que je vous
envie avec la pression l'urgence un
travail intellectuel n'est jamais fini
jamais jamais jamais résultat c'est
aussi l'une des sources des problèmes de
santé mentale
c'est que avec l'urgence qui est la
nôtre et le fait qu' on peut pas
garantir une qualité et bien on n'est
pas fiers comme celui qui a fait le
viaduc de millau pour les professionnels
c'est une source de désaffection ce que
je suis en train de vous dire vous
l'aurez compris à demi mot c'est que le
droit à la déconnexion qui me permet de
me déconnecter mon travail at il une
réalité
on y reviendra sans doute enfin je
termine nous sommes un société vers 10
ans tu es là que vous aimiez ou pas la
transition écologique
vous ne trouverez plus de collaborateurs
talentueux pour venir travailler que
l'entreprise qui reste dans l'ancien
système
outre les contraintes légales qu'on
verra et je me permets d'insister sur
deux articles du code civil par lequel a
du coup un coût du co2 travail l'eau du
code civil prakash der minerai qui
résume très bien ce que je vais vous
dire en leucate aude 82 2 4 août c'est
quand même important comptable de 4,82
monsieur au rouge je passe sur une loi
transitoire de 92 a fait voter un
article qui a révolutionné le droit du
travail aujourd'hui et syndicalistes se
disent on aurait peut-être dû faire plus
attention à cette promesse
d'individualisation que dit cet article
je résume
nul ne peut porter atteinte aux libertés
au pluriel sauf si c'est justifié
proportionnelle cette phrase est un
passage symbolique qui a tout changé
avec vingt ans d'écart personne n'a vu
venir le coup en 82 c'est maintenant
qu'on le voit venir c'est que derrière
cette phrase ya j'étais membre d'une
communauté de travail je me définissais
commune dans un cercle de pas comme une
hauteur mais grosso modo une entreprise
une collectivité de travail ces deux
termes du droit du travail nos
collectivités de travail et bien
maintenant si vous êtes des jeunes
collaborateurs
l'idée de le redire tout le monde porte
une blouse tu porte pas de jean tu viens
tous à la même heure tu partout c'est
complètement à côté de la plaque et ils
vous oppose l oms 121 les contraintes
que tu m'imposait ce qu'elles sont
justifiées par un tueur de tâches à
accomplir mais on en parlera paix dans
les discussions les entreprises vont
voir venir des juristes en particulier
qui leur diront qu'ils me demandent quoi
tu me demandent de revenir trois jours
dans l'entreprise donc je vais prendre
ma voiture comme sont 10% des français
je vais quitter ma famille qui s'est
fait à la présence du père ou de la mère
très bien mon conjoint n'en parlera pas
et tu existes que je le fasse mais tu
sûr que ton ordre soit justifiée par une
nature d'un ph accomplir que je fais
chez moi sur ordinateur et propose une
goutte rechercher s'il bonne idée de
prendre mon diesel pour faire 60 km à
leur dos et bien sûr c'est l'article 133
du code civil sur lequel je suis assez
partagé
la volonté est naturel et légitime
on l'a touché kossivi le quotidien comme
c'est le cas de tous les français jurent
c'est la base de notre cité france avec
aussi vilain ça n'a pas changé et bien
dans une loi pacte et je partage le font
incontestablement mais j'en attends les
conséquences si on tombe sur les jurys
c'est qu'une tête de forme de code
il en reste définition d'intérêt social
qui est pourquoi travail société ethera
deuxième alinéa dans l'exercice de
l'entreprise doit prendre en
considération les contraintes
je résume un social environnemental je
dois prendre en considération les
contraintes sociales droit du travail
rendant le fonctionnement en entreprise
et environnemental cet article a une
portée que peut être personne n'a
vraiment bien vu
j'en termine ce que je sais en train de
vous dire c'est que si le droit du
travail ne change pas eh bien il sera
contournée et il y aura faute de la
victime et je prends un exemple très
concret si vous êtes en télétravail à
votre domicile comme aujourd'hui et bien
soyons fous il faut vraiment être fou
mais parfois la folie à ses qualités
un salarié demande d'un inspecteur du
travail de venir vérifier ses conditions
de travail ce qui joue rappel pourrait
être parfaitement le cas puisque même
l'accord est approuvé celle du 26
novembre dit que les conditions de
travail au bureau
sont les mêmes domicile au domicile et
au bureau il ya il peut y avoir une
différence
alors je vais pas descendre dans les
tailles scarbrough mais avez vous chez
vous monsieur le président des grands
formats 80 cm sortie de secours avec
tous les 10 mai sortie de secours
est-ce que vos portes rompu 80 cm avez
vous un renouvellement de l'air de plus
de deux mètres cubes par 10 secondes et
puis bien sûr dans vos toilettes
avez-vous du parquet dix mille euros
les papiers peints 10000 euros ce que je
suis en train de vous dire c'est que on
peut pas en rester là
pour deux raisons j'ai terminé c'est le
droit du travail est conçu sur le modèle
ford taylor d'une entreprise collective
sur un lieu collectif propriété privée
d'une hache l entreprise dire que chez
moi dans mon domicile dans lequel ne
peut pas rentrer un officier de police
judiciaire l'est qu'en voyant sans
casser le home
le rapport de travail ne pleut plus être
le même c'est pas possible
mon hall ne va pas devenir un bureau bis
soumis au pouvoir de direction pouvoir
le séminaire tout ça pour vous dire que
je serai chez de l'entreprise
aujourd'hui je ne connaîtrais rien en
droit au travail
soyons faisons un rêve je redirai un
avocat dix mois
est-ce que j'embauche gens bougent pas
ben l'avocat si il sort d'une bonne
faculté dira puis ça aujourd'hui
travaillent à distance c'est très prisé
alors moi je dirais avons mais à quelle
distance châlons-sur-marne très bien
strasbourg très bien mais dis moi si mon
pêche de faire travailler mes
collaborateurs à bucarest ou à singapour
rien si ce n'est que du bout de vingt
deux cultures documenté mais la distance
aujourd'hui n'est plus synonyme
d'indépendance en clair je peux
commander pareil à strasbourg à l'île de
ré ou première chose à quelle distance
ne va pas y avoir des localisations et
c'est là où je mets en garde les
personnes qui disent il faut pas toucher
au droit du travail que si on touche par
exemple au temps de repos c'est toute la
chapelle sixtine qui va s'écrouler il
faut toucher à rien ça tout l'édifice
s'écroule
mais qu'est ce qui va se passer je dis
mon avocat pour me faire peur parce
qu'il a besoin de d'honoraires me disent
tu sais le travail à domicile c'est du
lourd 1 est ce que tu es toilettes
est-ce que des sorties secours et l'âge
éclate de rire et j'espère que c'est
d'humour juridique qui comme la musique
militaire n'a peu spécial
il voudra pas du tout pas du tout c'est
en cas de contrôle de l'inspection de
travail exemple tu dois twh et
entreprise donnée à la minute près et
pour même le forfait jour à la minute
près le temps de repos de tes cadres à
domicile et tu dis mais je ne peux pas
que je ne sais pas faire tout ça pour
vous dire que si le droit du travail ne
change pas il est en train de se
suicider parce qu'il ne fait pas face
aux nouvelles contraintes des
entreprises et des salariés sur le
travail à distance on a fait 2-2
rapprocher chez terra nova qui montre à
quel point ce que j'ai appelé le travail
confinait c'est-à-dire ce passage brutal
qu'on a connue en 2020 en avril on mars
et avril où on est passé brutalement
d'une proportion de 3 % des salariés qui
travaillaient plus d'un jour ou deux par
semaine kittel et travailler plus d'un
jour ou deux par semaine à 30% donc on a
multiplié par dix en un ou deux mois la
proportion des salariés qui étaient en
télétravail et sahamies le management en
tension ça a mené le management à
l'épreuve je paraphrase une expression
de warren buffett
à propos de la marée bleue fait dit que
c'est quand la marée se retire quand
distingue ceux qui nageaient sans
maillot c'est aussi quand le télétravail
se répand que l'on distingue les
managers qui ne sont pas capables
véritablement d'apporter un leadership
d'apporter un soutien professionnel
alors alors collaborateur alors quand je
parle du christ de la crise du
management et je me situe tout à fait
dans le dans le sillage de françois
dupuis la fatigue des élites lost in
management et son dernier ouvrage qui
sont tous très parlant sur le sujet la
crise du management c'est à la fois une
crise de légitimité et une crise de
désirabilité un chiffre passée inaperçue
mais qui me semble extrêmement important
dans le dernier baromètre de la cegos
sur le management
62e aujourd'hui dans les entreprises
françaises 62% des bons managers ne
veulent pas devenir ma nature c'est à
dire qu'il ya plus du tout cette saine
compétition qu'on a pu connaître
dans les années de croissance où
effectivement le chemin vers le
management était un chemin désirable et
désiré aujourd'hui ce de management et
dans les entreprises
et je parle notamment des entreprises
privées mais on pourrait élargir au
public
le management est plutôt un repoussoir
or moi je considère qu'un corps social
qui n'est plus capable de générer lui
même ses élites va à sa perte
et donc il est absolument nécessaire de
se poser
honnêtement et sans barrières la
question du pourquoi
pourquoi cette crise pourquoi ce
désamour pourquoi cette crise de
légitimité et de désir
si on ne répond pas à ces questions
alors on passera à côté et les
entreprises se trouveront véritablement
en situation difficile première chose à
observer c'est que ce malaise des
managers et celui des non ma nature
phrase au management
ce malaise les managers ida pas d'hier
dès 2009 la paix qui est l'association
qui justement épaules les cadres dans
leur mobilité professionnelle et
notamment leur mobilité externe mais
aussi internes
l'apec rendez compte déjà de ce
phénomène dans une enquête terrain
qu'elle avait effectuée très
intéressante qui montrait déjà à
l'époque environ la moitié des salariés
du secteur privé ne souhaitait pas passé
le cadre un jour dans leur carrière
de la même façon l'association des unes
des association de drh qui s'appelle
entreprise et personnel a publié en 2011
une étude dont le titre dit tout manager
de proximité non merci
voilà et cette étude relevé à
l'apparition je cite de signes d'un
désengagement croissant dont un certain
mal-être des managers de proximité et un
an plus tard donc 2012 le céreq centre
d'études et de recherches sur les
qualifications publié une étude par
nathalie bos cette fois ci très
qualitative là aussi le titre dit tout
redevenir cabre une perspective pas
toujours attrayantes
bon et si vous croisez ça avec ce que
nous disent les sociologues et les
psychologues du travail
je pense bien sûr à yves clôt à mathieu
d'être chez ca danièle linhart vincent
de gaulejac tous ont également attiré
l'attention sur les difficultés
aujourd'hui d'être d'être manager et je
mentionnais franck françois dupuis qui
depuis la fatigue des élites en 2005
tire le fil 2-2 de cette idée est de ce
point jusqu'à jusqu'à samson son dernier
ouvrage
et puis également denis monneuse qui est
un sociologue très intéressant qui a
écrit un livre dont le titre et le
silence des cadres enquête sur un balèze
donc là aussi ça dit tout ces sorties en
2014 donc tout ça et on pourrait
rappeler michel crozier dans les années
60 qui pointait déjà le retard du modèle
de management à la française qui
pointait et facit qui critiquait ce
qu'il appelait la pensée unique
managériale les modèles de gestion
archaïque et archi autoritaire et c'est
l'inertie mentale des dirigeants
notamment dans le phénomène
bureaucratique de michel crouzet qui
veulent du début des années 60
1963 exactement donc effectivement c'est
pas d'hier mais on n'arrive pas on
n'arrive pas à résoudre ce problème en
france alors qu'eux ils ne se pose pas
dans les mêmes termes
ailleurs les enquêtes comparatives
montrent que cette problématique de
l'ampleur du nombre des salariés qui ne
veulent pas devenir manager est plus
fort dans les sociétés la team france
italie espagne portugal qu'ailleurs en
europe ou aux états unis en australie ou
dans des contextes plus anglo-saxon donc
il ya véritablement une spécificité de
leurs platines et la france ne se
comporte pas mieux que les autres pays
d'europe latine notamment pas mieux que
l'italie et l'espagne sur lesquels on on
a des chiffres
alors donc il faut se poser la question
du pourquoi pour essayer de traiter
chacun des problèmes tant par exemple un
des premiers points c'est que l'intérêt
pécuniaire ne fait plus le poids
le seul avantage majoritairement perçue
par les noms manager quand on leur pose
la question du management
on leur dit quels sont les inconvénients
quels sont les avantages de devenir
manager à les salariés considèrent que
la balance n'est pas en faveur du du
management le seul avantage qu'ils
perçoivent c'est l'intérêt pécuniaire on
gagne mieux sa vie
voilà c'est ça qui sort très en tête
notamment dans dans les diverses
enquêtes qualitatives qui ont été faites
sur le sujet les autres avantages
ils sont pourtant extrêmement forts sont
beaucoup moins valorisé le fait par
exemple d'avoir davantage de
responsabilités le fait de partager
davantage à la prise de décision le fait
de pouvoir délégué du travail à ses
équipes
alors pourquoi tout simplement parce que
en france
le management est encore traitée l'eau
rien il est beaucoup plus hiérarchique
que que dans les autres pays
ben sociologue sociologue néerlandais
qui a fait des études très détaillé sur
ce qu'il appelle la distance
hiérarchique la distance hier à succès
hier la distance que les salariés
mettent entre eux et leur entre
guillemets la leur chef distance en
termes de rémunération en termes de
statut en termes de responsabilité et
bien cette distance hiérarchique est
plus forte en france
évidemment que depuis les pays
anglo-saxons où les collaborateurs sont
traités beaucoup plus sur un pied
d'égalité mais également vis-à-vis des
autres pays y compris de rampes l'été de
la tient et même la distance
hiérarchique en france est plus élevé au
japon qui est sans doute le pays
emblématiques en matière de respect de
la hiérarchie respect des anciens etc
donc on a véritablement un problème
spécifique en france 2e 2e pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a cette crise du
meretz plainte parce que les salariés
perçoivent un inconvénient majeur qui
est le surcroît de pression
le fait d'être responsable du travail
des autres génère un accroissement de la
charge de travail et du fameux fil à la
patte qui fait déborder le travail sur
la vie personnelle
on est en permanence connecté à son
travail quand on est manager nous disent
les répondants aux diverses enquêtes qui
ont été faibles tant que ça il faut le
gérer aussi il faut en tenir compte et
il faut faire en sorte que le management
est bien cesse d'être vécue comme un
rôle qui englue les gens qui se portent
volontaires dans des tâches
administratives de contrôle de reporting
se7en ferment dans le taylorisme fait
que en france les managers passe
beaucoup plus de temps qu'ailleurs à
faire du reporting notamment pour
rassurer leurs leur propre chef la
hiérarchie qui a déserté la scène du
travail qui ne comprend plus les
contraintes et les réalisations du
travail et donc ils pour se rassurer
demande d'états chief des indicateurs et
donc les managers en france sont englués
dans but reporting et dans des tâches de
de contrôle alors qu'il faut absolument
faire la transition qu'ont fait les
autres pays
enfin la plupart des autres pays qui
sont plus avancés dans la transition
vers un management qui repose non plus
sur l'obéissance mais sur l'adhésion qui
repose non plus sur la discipline mais
sur la participation sur l'adhésion des
ddd des salariés qui ont davantage
d'autonomie et qui repose davantage sur
le soutien professionnel
on devrait on doit passer moins de temps
à faire du reporting et les tâches de
contrôle et plus de temps à être en
soutien professionnel des collaborateurs
donc qu'est ce qu'on fait dans les
entreprises bah c'est ce que je fais par
exemple avec mes clients je les fais
travailler sur les attendus du
management qu'attendent les dirigeants
de leur manager qu'attend les managers
de leurs salariés et inversement
qu'attendent les salariés de leur
manager et qu'attendent les managers de
leurs dirigeants
quand vous fait travailler le corps
social sur sa sur ce type de questions
vous arrivez à faire que j'appelle moi
et managériale ou ont documenté attendu
et du coup ça permet d'alléger les
tâches de reporting et de contrôle à au
profit de tâche un peu plus valorisante
en plus pour les managers qui sont leur
participation au projet de développement
de l'entreprise et bien sûr le soutien
professionnel op collaborateurs
troisième raison de ce désamour
vis-à-vis du management c'est les
questions de compétence on s'aperçoit
que beaucoup de salariés ne veulent pas
être manager parce qu'ils estiment
qu'ils n'ont pas les compétences et là
on tombe sur une autre spécificité
française qui est la faiblesse de la
formation au management qui en france
est traité un peu comme du développement
personnel quoi on apprend les gens à
gérer leurs émotions etc
mais on ne leur apprend pas à gérer le
travail à manager le travail à manager
des personnes et beaucoup de gens sont
premiers managers le sont parce que ils
sont techniquement les meilleurs de leur
équipe mais pas du tout parce que ils
ont de l'appétence de l'intérêt pour les
autres donc ça fait aussi partie des
éléments qu'il faut qu'il faut changer
on a également dans le pourquoi la
question de la parité professionnelle
la question des femmes parce que
lorsqu'on est une femme est bien la
majeure partie des obstacles au
management sont accentuées conciliation
vie personnelle vie professionnelle
tendance accrue est complètement
infondée as estimé incompétent etc
et c'est là où il faut prendre la mesure
et on a une enquête européenne qui a été
fait par euro faible
la fondation de dublin qui est le bras
armé de la commission sur toutes les
questions du travail qui a montré qu'en
france plus qu'ailleurs la propre
l'écart entre la proportion des femmes
dans les salariés et la proportion des
femmes dans les managers elle est plus
forte en france qu'ailleurs c'est à dire
que quand vous êtes une femme vous avez
moins de chance de devenir manager quand
vous êtes en france quand vous êtes dans
n'importe quel autre pays des 27
européens
donc ça montre bien que on a une
difficulté on voit un problème du
conseil d'administration et du comex
mais pas seulement
y compris sur les premiers les premières
strates de management ton à cette
difficulté
voilà et puis pour finir sur mes forces
mais dix minutes je pense que il faut
aussi tenir compte dans l'est dans les
dents les freins du manque de
reconnaissance
le management en france et très peu
reconnu et quand vous regardez dans les
entreprises comment sont évalués les
managers ils sont très peu évalués sur
leur qualité managériale
ils sont beaucoup plus évalués sur des
choses très traditionnel leur production
les objectifs quantitatifs et très peu
ce véritablement sur leur qualité
managériale donc ça aussi ça fait partie
des grands chantiers de ce qu'il faut
absolument changer et l'enjeu n'est
l'enjeu n'est pas mince parce que il ya
un déficit de sens aujourd'hui tout le
monde le mantra des drh sait quel est le
sens du travail dans l'entreprise
et quel est le sens de l'entreprise dans
la société
c'est ces deux questions de sens qui
s'emboîtent dans les entreprises est
bien à l'articulation de ces deux
problématiques
il y a le management toutes les strates
du manager du manager lundi de proximité
à ce que les anglo-saxons appellent
first strike manager c'est là où on voit
que le management vient des militaires
les managers de premier rang ce qui sont
contact deux directement dans la
bataille
contact avec l'ennemi jusque au
management qu'on appelle aujourd'hui les
dirigeants c'est à dire ceux qui sont
proches du du commerce ou du ou du
comité de direction cesser ces
interactions là il faut absolument aller
gérer et il faut effectivement reposer
la question du sens dans les entreprises
de façon à ce qu'on retrouve des raisons
d'avoir envie d'être manager et qu'on
améliore le management dans les
entreprises qui est important à un rôle
absolument majeur parce que moi j'ai
publié avec avec l'anact et la fabrique
de l'industrie 1
un ouvrage sur la qualité de vie au
travail dans ses relations avec
l'organisation du travail avec les
organisations de l'entreprise et on a
montré que le manager de proximité joue
un rôle absolument essentiel sur la
qualité du travail dans les entreprises
et la santé au travail
donc voilà qu'elle est là la
problématique telle que je la voit se
dessiner aujourd'hui dans les
entreprises
merci monsieur riche et de votre
intervention donc je j'entends que
madame benhamou et des difficultés de
pour nous rejoindre
ok donc je vais donner la parole à nos
trois rapporteurs s'il m'entend je vais
commencer par fabien gay qui en vit en
visioconférence fabien la parole oui
bonjour sur le prison mercier messieurs
compromis luminaires là je vais essayer
de tenir ce que dit d'habitude monsieur
le président bahreïn je vais pas faire
leur discours je vais vous poser des
questions même si je vous avoue jeu
j'aimerais beaucoup de débats la
première c'est sur la question du
management
j'entends les réserves que vous dites
les évolutions du management sont
partagés notamment plusieurs exemples de
deux cadres d'entreprises qui me disent
on passe aujourd'hui plus de temps à
expliquer comment on travaille ou à
faire ce que vous dites mureaux porting
plutôt qu'à travailler ou en quadrettes
donc c'est une
c'est une c'est une c'est un problème et
je pense que le fossé s'est accentuée
pendant la crise sanitaire ce que vous
dites c'est que les cadres dirigeants ou
les hauts cadres se sont retrouvés
éloigné du système productif est ce que
vous appelez de l'encadrement de
proximité et il va avoir une difficulté
c'est comment après cette crise on
recrée du lien dans l'entreprise et que
le management ne comprennent l'ensemble
de sa place et si j'étais un peu
provocateur je dirais que par exemple
l'exemple de ce qui s'est passé à
renault lorsqu'on nous a dit que carlos
ghosn était le sauveur d'euros
et que lui même était le seul à même de
diriger rhône lorsqu'il a été emprisonné
et que ses fonctions rockliffe 1 qu'il
n'y avait pas de paix déjà redon
pourtant les entreprises de renault ont
continué à faire tourner l'entreprise et
les ouvriers ont continué à faire
l'entreprise ont une première question
quelles sont les pistes
parce que on a l'état des lieux mais
quelles sont les pistes aujourd'hui pour
véritablement aurait à moi je dirais un
système ou cadres cadres de proximité et
salariés employés ouvriers
si on parle on d'entreprise vraiment
métallurgique comment on peut avoir un
système qui fonctionne mieux et où les
cadres sont en prise directe je dirais
avec le travail et ne passent pas leur
temps réellement à commenter le travail
mais bien à être dans le travail la
deuxième question c'est sur le code du
travail j'entends les critiques
moi je pense qu'il faut une modification
du code du travail puisque le travail
s'est largement modifié comme vous
l'avez digne depuis depuis un siècle que
la question du télétravail est posée
maintenant avec force
vous avez raison des millions de
télétravailleurs si on nous avait dit ça
il ya un an personne n'aurait cru mais
j'entends la critique
j'entends là aussi le fort besoin de
changement mais quelles sont les pistes
aujourd'hui que nous pourrions tirer de
ces conclusions de cette première crise
et quelles qu'elles puissent nous
donnera y est pour faire évoluer et non
pas à rabattre sur les ambitions comme
du travail mais bien pour le faire
évoluer et ce qui a manqué vous le dis
et je finis par là comme ça je peux pas
trop lent monsieur le président je pense
que ce qui ce qui ce qui a manqué dans
l'analyse c'est le rapport de domination
entre les salariés et le capital est ce
qu'on appelle entre que les fons capital
et les forces du travail parce
qu'aujourd'hui les forces de travail ne
sont pas associés dans les entreprises à
la co direction de l'entreprise
important
un certain nombre de sociologues travail
sur cette question vous l'avez ski c'est
un peu je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
d'intelligence dans la classe ouvrière
et que si on laisse pousser les
questions ils ont des pistes pour faire
évoluer leur travail et leur entreprise
mais aujourd'hui ils n'ont aucun lieu
pour pousser ces débats voilà c'est
surtout après les critiques et un état
de fait
quelles pistes on pousse ensemble voilà
je vous remercie j'espère ne pas avoir
été trop loin très bien fabien tu étais
très bien dans le temps alors on va sur
les questions on va les dents on va
reprendre dans leurs deux interventions
parce que finalement ça correspond aux
interrogations de notre collègue alors
monsieur dupuis ensuite le droit du
travail et puis monsieur riche et
peut-être sur le hp général de du sujet
monsieur dupuis asie bien
alors pour donner une réponse fausse
note hausse s qui c'est une réponse
concrète ce qui vient d'être dit
je voulais partir d'une définition qui
peut être vous sera sursauter du
management
parce qu'elle n'est pas politiquement
correct car après tout depuis le début
on parle d'une manette mais qu'est ce
que c'est le management ça consiste à
quoi et bien c'est moi j'ai jamais
trouvé de meilleure définition plus
simple que de dire le management ça
consiste à obtenir que les gens fassent
ce que vous souhaiteriez qu'il fasse
voilà et donc la question qui se trouve
posée c'est comment vous y arrivez
comment vous faites pour que les gens
fassent ce que l'on souhaiterait qu'il
fasse alors bien sûr par rapport à 7 à
cette question là je suis extrêmement
frappé d'un mouvement du management
crier l'individualisation des réponses
apportées
c'est à dire que vous vous observerez
par exemple qu'il ya eu une explosion du
coaching
c'est d'ailleurs un de ses joueurs les
coaches coachs seront les coachs c'est
aussi la thaïlande que je vois pas
comment il pourrait en être autrement
et alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire
l'explosion du coaching
ça veut dire que on renonce à traiter la
question du management dire encore
devons obtenir des gens qui fassent que
l'on souhaite qu'il fasse
on renonce à la traiter dans la
complexité organisationnelle pour la
traiter sur un mode purement
individuelle est alors la traiter sur un
manquement individuel est tout à fait
culpabilisateur parce que ça
s'accompagne du coup de l'apparition et
du développement de ce monde bateau dans
une toujours pas compris le sens
personnellement qui est le leader j'ai
pas ce que ça veut dire moi le leader le
leadership c'est encore une fois c'est
renvoyé vers les qualités individuelles
de manager et caetera et caetera et vous
aurez observé d'ailleurs une chose tous
je le suppose c'est que pendant cette
crise
eh ben vous pouvez parcourir linkedin
vous verrez que le thème du leader et du
leadership a disparu on le voit plus où
on le voit quasiment plus alors je ne
doute pas qu'il réapparaisse parce qu'il
ya trop de gens qui ont intérêt à ce que
ce thème du leadership reviennent sur le
devant de la scène mais elle a disparu
comme je l'aï expliqué tout à l'heure
parce que il s'adresse ce thème du
leadership à de l'encadrement
intermédiaire
eolys il faut regarder comment
fonctionnent les business rouges ont
fait 3 à cet encadrement intermédiaire
qui est celui qui peuplent les business
school qu'il a une vocation à devenir un
leader et c'est donc ça maximise le rôle
d'un certain point de vue on le raconte
à un petit peu d histoire alors par
rapport à ce que vous avez dit
l'encadrement de proximité je le répète
comme je les dis à jouer un rôle tout à
fait fondamentale et qui s'est accrue
moi j'utilise une expression là dessus
jeudi les sergents chefs ont retrouvé
leur bâton de maréchal dans la crise
s'avèrent véritablement jusque là il
était sergent chef au sens où il était
simplement supposé faire exécuter ce qui
venait du jour
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure ils
n'ont pas fait écouter ce qu'ils
venaient du haut parce qu'on paie pas
fonctionné comme ça et c'est comme ça
que ça a marché et personne s'est bien
gardé de le leur reprocher maintenant je
vais vous dire un autre rôle suite à
cette crise que va avoir le
l'entraînement de proximité et je vais
faire référence à quelque chose qui a
dit jean emmanuel tout à leur âge ou ce
titre on se serait jamais attendu à ce
qu'il y ait ce nombre de gens qui se
retrouvent en télétravail comme tu l'as
dit c'est vraiment ça a été une surprise
mais ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que la période que nous avons vécu et
notamment celle du passage au
télétravail a généré des exclusions et
c'est quelque chose que l'on ne retrouve
nulle part
tout le monde sait ce bogie de
télétravail de ce que ça donne et c'est
mais ça a généré des exclusions essaie d
exclusion qu'il faudra rattraper
il ya eu dans les entreprises de type
d'exclusion
le premier type d'exclusion il était au
problème des bandes passantes ce que
c'est technologique mais si vous voulez
passer un maximum de gens en télétravail
encore faut-il que les bandes passantes
dont vous disposez dans vos systèmes
informatiques sont suffisamment large
pour accueillir tout le monde et dans
l'échantillon que nous nous avions
aucune des entreprises considérées il
avait des bande passante suffisante et
par conséquent qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que les entreprises
ont fait des choix en disant ben on va
d'abord connecter ceux là qui sont les
plus essentiels pour arriver à
poursuivre l'activité
les autres ils attendront et il a fallu
quelquefois attendre jusqu'à un mois un
mois et demi l'élargissement de la bande
passante
qu'est ce que ça a donné du coup ça a
donné toute une population qui s'est
interrogé sûr mais quelle est la valeur
de mon travail
quelle est la réalité de mon travail à
quoi je sers dans l'entreprise puisqu'on
me connecte même pas et donc je ne peux
pas participer à la vie de l'entreprise
et savez vous que nous avons constaté
une chose c'est que cette population qui
a été exclu d'un point de vue
technologique et la population qui au
mois de juillet entre juillet et
septembre a été la plus réticente à
revenir en présentiel
elle avait été exclue des facto par les
problèmes des collections et elle a été
ensuite réticente
c'est la réponse du berger à la bergère
à revenir en présentiel et donc ça cela
réintégration de cette catégorie de
cette catégorie de gens ça va être le
rôle effectivement de l'encadrement de
proximité et ça va être le rôle dans les
temps à venir et l'a26 à une deuxième
processus d'exclusion m'excuse mais
comme je dis souvent pour m'amuser
plaisanterie de sociologues cette fois
ci pas de juristes la différence entre
la sociologie et ce qui se passe dans
les entreprises c'est que les
entreprises sont des lieux d'abstraction
absolument extraordinaire on ne parle
que deux choses totalement abstraite
dans les entreprises
alors que les socialo de le parlent de
choses concrètes c'est la grande
différence entre les voilà les managers
et les sociologues mais il ya eu un
deuxième phénomène d'exclusion que tout
le monde a semblé ignorer quand les
entreprises ont eu à désigner à leurs
salariés des plateformes que ça soit
zoom kim ce lac tout ce que vous voulez
pour communiquer elles ont dit les
réunions se feront par cette plateforme
et vous avez interdiction d'en utiliser
une autre toutes les entreprises soit
pas interdit d'en utiliser une autre
mais elle est salariée on dire mais vous
êtes gentil mais on va faire
différemment et il se trouve
et là j'ai pas le temps de troll
développer vous allez voir le lien très
fort qui l'a eue entre confinement et
d'autre part télétravail
il se trouve que dans le début du
conflit de mots contraire puisque l'une
des entreprises sous à laquelle nous a
travaillé voulons travailler nous a
demandé de faire une étude comparative
sur les français et les américains face
au confinement au premier confinement et
c'était fort bien vécu et ce que nous
avons constaté c'est que contrairement à
ce que la presse avaient raconté sans
bien sûr l'avoir vérifiée mais sa patrie
de l'importance pour la presse
contrairement à ce que la presse avait
annoncé c'est à dire que à ben le mari
la femme et les enfants tout le monde va
se battre les familles vont exploser et
cetera il s'est passé le contraire c'est
à dire que ça à rapprocher les familles
aussi bien la famille nucléiques c'est à
dire le père la mère et les enfants que
la famille élargie
voyez ce que ça veut dire et comment ce
rapprochement sur la famille élargie en
particulier ses produits
il s'est produit par le fait qu'on a
créé des groupes je vais citer vous
faisait awsat aux a créé des goûts
familiale des groupes loi de sade et
quand les salariés on leur a dit ouais
vous ne pouvez communiquer que par
l'intermédiaire de la plate forme qu'on
vous indique les salariés ont dit tu
sais on s'en fiche on va se créer des
groupes ou whatsapp à nous et on va
travailler à travers ces groupes est
simple oui mais quel est le problème
c'est que les gros poids de 5 l oms qui
l'ont créé ont été des groupes
affinitaires pas des collectifs de
travail c'est à dire qu'ils ont dit
aubin dans le groupe à de simples que
l'on crie on veut mettre madame untel
monsieur untel mademoiselle un tel
monsieur untel et c'est parce qu'il nous
sommes qu'il travaille bien parce qu'ils
vont pouvoir nous aider parce qu'on
s'entend bien et caetera et du coup on a
exclu ce dont on disait ce site des
extraits d'interviews suis là où celle
là il faut rien au boulot y'a pas de
raison la bête dans un gros parce qu'il
ou elle n'en fera pas plus dans le
groupe
et donc ça a produit un deuxième
phénomène d'exclusion et là encore il va
falloir le rattraper et ce sera le rôle
de l'encadrement de proximité
donc on voit bien on voit bien que ce
rôle encore une fois et vous avez raison
que je risque de la voir souligné ce
rôle extraordinairement important de
l'encadrement de proximité déjà en
période normale c'est totalement accrue
dans la période que nous sommes en train
de vision et de ce point de vue là je
voudrais attirer l'attention sur un
dernier point moi je suis toujours
surpris que l'on parle du terme
générique de management parce que le
management ça recouvre des catégories
différentes
ça prouve aussi bien les cadres
dirigeants que soit la peine les cadres
intermédiaires ou l'encadrement de
proximité et une des difficultés par
rapport à la crise du management que
vous avez souligné
j'ouvre elle a souligné en termes
simples
nous vivons dans un système dans lequel
parce que quelqu'un est techniquement
performants
on le trouve e manager c'est à la base
de la promotion de manager c'est
quelqu'un qui est le plus performant
techniquement dans son activité
mais c'est parce que vous êtes affirmant
dans votre actif
tant que vous êtes performant dans le
management donc ça donne ensuite des
phénomènes qui sont des phénomènes
extrêmes dans ce surprenant qui sont des
phénomènes des chèques etc etc et le
dernier point que je voudrais souligner
il est le suivant vous avez eu raison de
souligner mme sirleaf est quelque chose
qui est important c'est que avant cette
crise quand on regardait fonctionner ce
management de proximité dont je parle
j'ai pas vous allez par exemple une
ligne de production
vous avez là une ligne de production
vous allez voir le patron de la ligne et
vous allez voir qu'il a un petit bureau
vous discutez avec lui il va vous
expliquer ceci moi je passe beaucoup
plus de temps à remplir des états ces
états que me demande les fonctions
supports dont je parlais tout à l'heure
que moi personnellement je considère moi
managers de proximité comme inutile et
il se passe beaucoup plus de temps à
remplir ses états qu'à m'occuper du
fonctionnement de la ligne
et bien ce qui est très important c'est
que la crise à renverser cette logique
là et que s'il ya aujourd'hui un enjeu
comme je le disais tout à l'heure c'est
de savoir est-ce qu'on va revenir à la
situation antérieure
moi je n'ai pas de réponse à ça où est
ce que l'on va apprendre là tu es si on
en prend acte
ça nous amènera à poser une question
qu'on n'a pas abordé pour le moment et
que je n'ai pas abordés dès qu'on
abordera plus tard si ça vous intéresse
ça voudra dire qu'enfin on va
réintroduire de la confiance dans le
management
parce qu'aujourd'hui la confiance dans
le management c'est un slogan mais
compte tenu de la complexité de cette
question de la confiance au travail ça
n'est pas encore une réalité et si ma
foi cette crise pouvait déboucher là
dessus c'est à dire ah ok on a compris
qu'on peut faire beaucoup plus confiance
qu'on le faisait précédemment
eh bien ma foi on aurait peut-être fait
un progrès important dans le
fonctionnement du management
alors monsieur est donc le code du
travail d'écriture évolution foulée seul
vraiment le mot sur le management pour
poursuivre ce qui vient dire mon
collègue parce qu'on peut pas ignorer
que quand vous dites un jeune manager tu
vas prendre la suite et d'une équipe et
qu'ils consultent un ami avocat ou
étudiants pas rien et qui dit qu'est ce
que je risque est là c'est un débat que
vous avez également ici me semble-t-il
monsieur le président c'est
l'élargissement permanent de la
responsabilité pénale de l'ensemble des
responsables dissuade absolument les
personnes de prendre des responsabilités
et pas envoyer la définition du
harcèlement moral aujourd'hui et nous on
a créé le harcèlement managérial pour
vous êtes manager et qu'on vous dit tout
va faire du harcèlement managérial vous
dites ça coûte combien et on vous dit
trois ans de prison
il ya de quoi faire réfléchir un manager
qui peut prendre la stabilité je ne
disconvient pas sur le fait que le
harcèlement existe mais quand on prend
dix reçoit 8 et grandit jeu mais parce
que c'est un différend entre le civil et
p17 le pénal c'est moi qui passe en
correctionnelle il se pourrait pas dire
c'est mon patron qui m'a obligé c'est
l'aspect pénal et personnelle et dans
ces cas là j'ouvre pas de détails
les personnes morales non en elle-même
aucune morale c'est les dirigeants des
personnes morales connu qu'une éthique
quand ça tourne mal beaucoup de managers
sont laissés au bord de la route ça
encourage pas prendre des
responsabilités
deuxièmement sur le code alors je le
redis une seconde fois
je relis une seconde fois on assiste à
cause ou grâce au télétravail c'était
matériel à une polarisation absolue de
société il ya les happy few votre
serviteur peut-être vous grosso modo des
travailleurs intellectuels qui peuvent
travailler où ils veulent quand ils
veulent sauf les contraintes habituelles
pour moi les cours pour voulait etc et
qui sont very happy parce que c'est une
autonomie et frappé qu'on en parlant de
terminer c'est le désir des jeunes
générations qui est maintenant partagée
par tous les sondages c'est de
l'autonomie des marges de manoeuvre
c'est ça la nouvelle revendication c'est
plus une harmonisation salariale attend
donc ces happy few son very very happy
mais very very few de quoi et donc là je
rebondis sur ce qu'a dit l'intervenant
il va soi que pas une seconde je pense
qu'il faille abrogé que du travail parce
qu'il ya quand même des personnes sans
subordination
il ya des chaînes de production en
france donc
je n'en disconviens pas mais le message
que je voulais faire passer ces on est
en train d'entrer dans l'avenir à
reculons
j'en prends deux exemples et après je
vous reposer les solutions premier
exemple le forfait jour le forfait jour
est un aveu de martine aubry qui
consiste à dire et je suis pas très
favorable aux 35 heures en soi mais là
c'est une idée de génie
on est unique au monde l'idée c'est quoi
c'est un aveu et qui n'a pas satisfait
son camp c'est de dire avec les 35
heures l'entreprise vont se mettre à
contrôler le temps de travail et la
minute près parce que en clair avant il
y avait des pauses informel maintenant
on va calculer le temps de travail et
madame aubry eu l'excellente idée de
dire est ce qu on sait qu elle qu'elle
était en travail des experts de price de
arthur andersen qui sont dans les indes
dans les avions dans les salles
d'attentes est ce qu'on va mettre des
puces dont les attaché-case des cartes
quand c'est verticale en contre donc
madame aubry a eu parfaitement raison de
dire on va pas créer une usine à gaz à
la française à double tubulures inversée
on va changer de logique
est ce que je suis en train de vous dire
c'est ce que je souhaite et je réponds à
l'intervenant ce que je souhaite c'est
ce qu'a fait madame aubry sur le temps
de travail
en un mot il ya un moment faut arrêter
quoi ce sens sabre et bien il faudrait
le faire sur le lieu de travail il faut
trouver l'équivalent du passage au
forfait jours en matière de lieu de
travail et j'en termine sur le forfait
jour et la jurisprudence est habitué
mais foucades
la jurisprudence est resté sur le modèle
parce que c'est naturel le code du
travail ne parle mais aucun que du
travail européenne parle de jours ils
parlent de ré de minutes
rien ne parle le forfait jour résultat
quand les procès sont arrive à la cour
de cassation dans la crau cassation et
s'est réfugié sur ce qu'elle tenait bien
et résultats tenez vous bien si quand
même une le contraire du forfait jour
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas le
forfait au forfait jours et réserver les
cadres autonomes des cadres autonomes
sans sa incarne le chef de rayon il
n'est pas forfait jours et tenez vous
bien la jurisprudence
asphyxié tellement le forfait jour on a
beau le seul truc est adaptée à ses
cartes dans son très bon temps la
jurisprudence dit grosso modo si tu fais
4e pointe et tu fais pointe était garé
autonome comme ça tu es tranquille tu
pourras tu expliquer ce temps de repos
mais le propre des cadres autonomes ceux
qui pointent pas que je sais c'est ont
menacé
anouk simorrain cadres autonomes qui
pointe en un mot là une opportunité et
je réponds il faudrait commencer que par
le fait que les juges laissent vivre le
forfait jour parce que je vous rappelle
que la seule population satisfait 35
heures c'est pas les ouvriers c'est pas
les employés c'est les cartons parce que
au forfait jours de travail a
correspondu des forfaits jours de repos
edit à des cadres en forfait jours
est ce que tu es prêt à négocier ils
vous diront on ne pousse pas au forfait
jours ça me permet de partie avec mes
enfants en février ou en amour voilà un
système novateur qui est en train d'être
asphyxié par la jurisprudence
deuxième exemple le télétravail je
maintiens ce que j'ai dit c'est c'est
plus confortable pour le juré de dire de
se mettre la tête dans le sable
l'autruche en disant je ne veux pas
toucher au code du travail a connu des
travail que tout va tomber alors si vous
permettez je prends un exemple qui ira
droit au coeur aux au coeur des jeunes
papas des jeunes mamans excusez-moi j'ai
parlé de la vraie vie pas du code de la
vraie vie est-ce que je vous dirais très
illégal donc tenez vous bien c'est
respirer fort je suis chez moi en
télétravail
je suis je ne pas pas très fier et ma
petite juliette trois ans va bientôt
sortir de la maternelle je suis en train
de travailler de fermer powerpoint et je
vois 16h30 et j'imagine la juliette qui
va sortir tout seul qui va être prise en
charge par quelqu'un et je me dis quand
même on n'a qu'une vie et donc je vais
aller chercher juliette
mais qu'est ce que je fais alors là je
ne vais pas donner de recettes aux
travailleurs à distance mais tous les
professionnels travaillent hissant
savent qu'on peut faire semblant de
travailler à distance en un mot on fait
tourner l'ordinateur on décroche le
téléphone en un mot faut pas penser moi
ça on le sait en dix minutes on sait
très bien faire donc je m'enroule mon
logiciel pour faire comme si que je
décroche mon téléphone et je vais
chercher julienne et là il ya que les
jeunes papas qui pourront comprendre
père que moi je me suis dit j'ai dix
minutes pour ses gilets je l'embrassé
craque je revends de travailler ça se
passe jamais comme ça papa est ce que je
peux par une crêpe non non non oui pas
parce qu'on peut faire un tour lent
réponse non
oui je vous passe le reste et on se
retrouve à 19h30
le papa est heureux ça économise 20 ans
de psychanalyse de juliette 20 ans après
en un mot tout le monde
j'assiste à quoi ça sert de créer china
gas alors qu'aline opportunité
exceptionnelle de créer des liens
exceptionnels
résultat je me mets au travail à 21h et
là en cas de contrôle la session de
travail
mon employeur et mal de chez mal de chez
mal parce que travail de nuit non
déclaré je vous fais pas de dessin ça
peut s'allumer en correctionnelle voilà
l'exemple ce que moi d'être aussi
pratico pratique mais moi le droit n'a
d'intérêt que si correspond au besoin la
société sils en cas de valablement le
voir patronale résultat le télétravail
et c'est une déception mais on ne change
pas le monde en un jour
l'accord national interprofessionnel du
26 novembre signé par tous les syndicats
sauf la cgt et tous les employeurs et
bien qu'est ce qui dit il reproduit le
modèle légal habituel 10 ans chez soi
c'est pareil qu'au bureau sur ce il ya
une assise qui montrent qu'on change qui
a donné lieu à discussion serrée
vindicative une phrase on voit que ça
commence à changer
il est cependant rappelé grosso modo à
coups de louche que le contrôle patronal
au domicile ne peut pas être le même que
contre le patronat dans les bureaux web
as on voit que là il ya un aveu en amour
on va pas se jouer alors on me demande
qu'est ce que je propose est
parfaitement raison la critique est
facile et l'art est difficile
d'accord n'importe quel crétin est
capable de poser les problèmes il faut
les solutions c'est comme ça qu'on
apprend droit pas rien encore à partir
de là je prends un exemple
hubert parce que libé risation se
rappeler d'une conséquence du
télétravail au caire hubert et là je
pose la question à tous ceux qui sont
ici présents et j'ai eu l'honneur de
faire partir la commission froid qui a
réfléchi pendant neuf mois sur est ce
que les travailleurs hubert son salarié
pas salarié est ce qu'il faut on a
écouté des dizaines
vrai travailleur hubert ce qu'ils ont
dans leurs taxis sur leur vitesse aide
et on leur a dit moi le premier le
juriste de service c'est alors pourquoi
vous assignez hubert des libéraux aux
prud'hommes hélas si j'étais un peu naïf
les jurys sont rarement naïf je leur ai
dit est ce que c'est pour trouver un
employeur
je vous prie monsieur le président je ne
répéterai pas les réponses qui m'ont été
faites
elle était parfois à la limite de la
politesse c'était bien sûr que nous on
veut pas de patron on cherche pas un
lien de subordination
on veut des horaires libres moi j'ai pas
envie de me lever à 5 heures parce que
le patron m'a dit tu iras bobigny
chercher à inclure moteur ce qu'on veut
c'est la protection sociale parce que
figure toi que dans une voiture les
accidents sur mon vélo j'ai déjà eu deux
accidents et la voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est la question du droit du
travail en france est très spécial c'est
que le droit du travail un lien
irréfragable avec la protection sociale
du meilleur régime qui le régime général
et selon qu'on s'est aperçu dans la
pollution foin c'est que la
revendication apparente
je cherche un contrat de travail n'est
pas le fond de la revendication sur le
plan collectif c'est on va mettre la
pression sur hubert parce que s'il ya
plein de contentieux hubert va lâcher ce
qui s'est révélé exact corps et sur le
plan individuel et j'en terminerai pour
la question je sais pas si vous avez des
enfants
est-ce que vos enfants aujourd'hui on
court fantasmes je vais rentrer à l'état
juif de la tour gan et dans 30 ans je
serai aux laitages 28 de la tour gan
on pourra parler si vous souhaitez de la
génération y qui dit tout faux tout haut
et fort ce que pensait beaucoup
génération après l a dit et l'a mis sur
la table qu'on n'osait pas dire en un
mot ce que je vais vous dire c'est que
la subordination avis n'est pas un idéal
insurpassable et donc allons-y
on quitte le droit du travail et on va
dans la protection sociale ils ont
terminé à part cet exemple là si vous
voulez bien c'est est-ce qu'une jeune
femme qui accouche a besoin de repos la
réponse est oui et là excusez moi cette
provocation
est ce qu'une femme agricultrice a
besoin de moins de repos qu'une femme
salariée qui elle a besoin de moins de
repos qu'une femme artisans qu'elle
remisé moins de repos qu'un commerçant
en un mot il ya des droits fondamentaux
de la personne qui travaille quel que
soit son statut
moi mes étudiants certains sont trois
heures vtc l'hôte d'autres formations
ils ont des cdd chez mcdo en un mot ce
sont ce qu'on appelle et slasher
et là on élague de système mais si c'est
le progrès social est conçu sur toute ta
vie tu feras même chose là aussi on sent
que ça on s'en sert plus et c'est ce
qu'a proposé alain supiot depuis 20 ans
depuis 20 ans c est là c'est un effort
considérable et on va me dire c'est pas
le moment
mais grosso modo on va pas décaler le
coût du travail pour les artisans s'est
passée la question on va faire la liste
des droits fondamentaux de la personne y
travaillent une femme est enceinte et la
couche balade roi s'en c'est pas
le statut juridique qui fait la fatigue
la femme le chômage
on l'a bien vu avec les vtc avec la
crise quels sont les droits fondamentaux
de l'homme au travail qui seront
couverts et c'est là évidemment et je
m'arrête là parce que sans ça on va en
parler pendant huit jours
c'est ça peut pas être basées sur les
cotisations sociales patronales et
salariales
puisque on quitte le salariat ça veut
dire que ce sera forcément fiscalisés et
là évidemment si on en parle à bercy vu
les sommes en cause ce n'est pas le
moment effectivement c'est rarement le
moment je vais demander à monsieur riche
et son intervention sur les termes du
questionnement de fabien gay particulier
sur la relation hiérarchique dans le
monde du management entre les dirigeants
lesquels et cadres intermédiaires les
cas les exécutants et en est très
volontiers effectivement fabien gay me
semble-t-il pose la question essentielle
des leviers qu'est ce qu'il faut faire à
quai et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
concrètement
moi j'en vois 5 1 je vais passer très
rapidement sur chacun mais je vois cinq
leviers qui pourraient véritablement à
être utilement mis en oeuvre dans
l'objectif d'améliorer le management
dans les entreprises et plus
généralement d'améliorer la qualité de
vie au travail la santé au travail et la
qualité du travail lui-même le premier
mass est justement de réinstaller le
travail au centre de l'entreprise et de
son fonctionnement
bon là je fais référence à un excellent
bouquin de pierre-yves gomez que vous
connaissez sans doute le travail
invisible enquête sur une disparition
qui est sortie en 2013 qui montre je
caricature et je résume bras
la shdm et qui montrent que le grand
voile qui a été jeté sur les entreprises
dans la phase de financiarisation de
l'économie à partir du début des années
80 a évacué le travail en dehors des
limites organisationnelle des
entreprises et a fait que le travail est
devenu invisible dans les entreprises et
c'est à ça qu'il faut mettre fin et
beaucoup d'entreprises scission me déjà
et pas toujours les entreprises qu'on
estime les plus vertueuses par exemple
un modèle dans le genre c'est google a
plein de choses à reprocher à google
mais en contrepartie google a fait un
excellent travail sur la question du
management et de la visibilité du
travail alors ça veut dire quoi
concrètement rendre le travail à nouveau
visible ça veut dire que on prend tous
les process de l'entreprise
le recrutement l'évaluation des
collaborateurs la formation et c'est à
tous les processus et on se pose la
question de la place du travail dans ces
processus allant j'en prends un qui est
peut-être le plus important qui est
l'évaluation des collaborateurs dans un
certain nombre d'entreprises
l'évaluation des collaborateurs est
devenu un processus complètement
désincarné où on ne parle jamais du
travail on ne fait que une fois par an
par exemple et en remplissant en cochant
des cases sur un logiciel même parfois
on fait ça à distance
on ne fait que dire alors ok tel
objectif que tu avais est-ce qu'il est
est ce que tu as rempli l'objectif à 50%
à 100% à 120% et ont rempli les cases et
puis à la fin le logiciel calcule une
dot et puis on se base pour déterminer
si on raccroche ou pas s'il y aura
augmentation salariale pasche
donc voilà le travail est complètement
évacué remettre le travail au centre du
fonctionnement de l'entreprise ça veut
dire concrètement dans l'exemple de ce
processus là l'évaluation des
collaborateurs une discussion franche et
ouverte entre le collaborateur et son
manager sur qu'est ce qui est difficile
dans le travail
en quoi le travail a changé cette année
où ce trimestre par rapport à avant
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour
contourner les obstacles donc une vraie
discussion ou
pour du travail et de ses de son
agressivité de ses difficultés
deuxième exemple pour rendre le travail
à nouveau visible mais c'est tout ce que
préconise yves clot tout ce qui a été
fait à l'usiné de flins de de renom et
tout ce qui est cher monsieur je pense à
fabien gay autour de la controverse
d'organiser la controverse autour du
travail c'est-à-dire aménagés dans les
entreprises des espaces de discussion
sécurisé en mettant à distance la ligne
hiérarchique pour permettre aux salariés
de parler tranquillement et en sécurité
de ce qui ne va pas dans le travail
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'arrive jamais à
bien bosser avec les gens du marketing
pourquoi est ce que on est toujours à la
bourre parce qu'en nous on va tous nous
a pas permis d'anticiper sur les
contraintes de notre travail
qu'est ce qui ne va pas dans le travail
et qu'est-ce qui au contraire pas bien
et c'est dans les entreprises où on
arrive à avoir ces discussions où on
fait tenir au management un rôle utile
qui n'est pas le rôle du flic et la
parole des collaborateurs mais qui au
contraire est le rôle de prendre cette
matière est d'être capable d'en tirer
des nouvelles règles des nouveaux modes
de management pour revenir vers les
salariés en disant voilà dans la
dernière réunion
vous avez dit ça ça et ça voilà ce qu'on
propose de faire pour résoudre le
problème
voilà c'est dans les entreprises où se
dit alors autour du travail est ouvert
il peut se dérouler sans trop d'accrocs
qu'on réussit à améliorer la situation
donc ça c'est mon premier levier c'est
remettre le travail non pas au coeur de
l'entreprise mais au coeur du
fonctionnement entreprises soyons
concrets deuxième levier qui est
absolument majeur c'est de mandater la
fonction ressources humaines
la fonction rh a déserté la question du
management depuis une dizaine d'années
c'est à dire elle n'est plus vu comme
une fonction qui est capable de réguler
d'apporter des éléments de régulation
sur le management la dernière enquête de
l'igpn sur le management montrent que
il n'ya plus que 17% des salariés qui
cite la drh parmi les fonctions les plus
susceptibles de transformer la culture
et les modes de management dans leur
entreprise 17 % c'est tout petit et
quand vous regarder uniquement les
réponses des cadres ça tombe encore à 8%
donc la rh est devenu et ouvrait les
vannes comme on dit de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique est elle n'est plus
dangereux
eh bien il faut absolument la remettre
dans le jeu pourquoi parce que c'est la
rh qui a les leviers pour faire avancer
les choses sur ce plan là donc là je
dois avoir un mandat clair qui est de
recréer de réinventer le management dans
l'entreprise un manager qui satisfasse à
la fois à ce duo les dirigeants et ceux
du bas entre 10 mai les salariés dont
trouver ce juste équilibre
troisième levier qui pour moi est des
majeures c'est ce que j'avais le soutien
média
c'est à dire que les dirigeants de
l'entreprise doivent s'investir dans le
soutien de la ligne managériale
si on veut que les changements
maintenant d'ailleurs on parle plus de
changements on parle transformation la
transformation c'est la même chose que
le changement mais en plus cher et on
veut que les transformations se déroule
de bonne façon c'est à dire sans créer
des externalités négatives sans créer de
souffrance de douleurs de risques
psychosociaux de stress de harcèlement
d'irritabilité eh bien il faut que la
chaîne managériale soit solidaire ans
aujourd'hui c'est clair
les managers sont entre le marteau le
marteau et l'enclume
on leur demande trop duo et on attend
trop 2 du bas donc il faut être clair
sur ce qu'on veut et exactement et c'est
pour ça je vous parlais tout à l'heure
d'un d'un outil très concrète le que
j'ai trouvé qu'ils aient la charte
managériale qui permet justement est
bien de faire en gaule la proche de la
controverse autour du travail gueule que
je mentionnais tout à l'heure de faire
la même chose pour les managers c'est à
dire de faire une controverse sur le
management
ok c'est quoi le management dans notre
entreprise aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui
difficile qu'est ce qui ne l'est pas
comment on peut l'améliorer avoir cette
discussion de façon ouverte
pour permettre de trouver un troc qui
fasse gagner tout le monde - 2 - dorée
portier mois de contrôle et plus de
soutien professionnel plus de
participation des managers aux tâches de
développement développement commercial
développement des personnes
rh et c'est donc le soutien algeria les
dirigeants doivent absolument s'engager
davantage pour soutenir la ligne
managériale dernière enquête de la cegos
seuls 18% des managers en france sont
pleinement d'accord pour affirmer qu'ils
ont suffisamment de visibilité sur la
stratégie de l'organisation
si les dirigeants ne donne pas de
visibilité sur la stratégie alors
manager comment peuvent-ils espérer que
les managers soutiennent les projets de
transformation seuls 17% des managers
c'est les managers qu'on interroge 17%
et manager affirme recevoir des
informations claires et adaptées de la
part de leur hiérarchie
seuls 15 % se sentent accompagné par la
direction des ressources humaines et par
leur propre management les managers se
sentent seuls
ils se sentent abandonnés au milieu de
la jungle balladuriens donc voilà
soutien managériale c'est mon troisième
levier quatrième levier c'est ce que
j'ai appelé tout à l'heure le soutien
professionnel s'est allié à aménager
cette transition entre un management qui
aujourd'hui fonctionne sur l'obéissance
et la discipline vers un management qui
fonctionne sur l'adhésion et le soutien
je cherche l'adhésion de mes
collaborateurs donc je les fais
participer aux décisions
je les inclus je je je je fais en sorte
qu'ils soient véritablement partie de
l'organisation et là ça n'est rien
d'autre que la mise en oeuvre du de la
constitution du principe constitutionnel
qui dit que chaque travailleur a son mot
à dire dans l'organisation du travail ça
n'est rien d'autre que la mise en oeuvre
de ce2 ce2 ce principe mais on l'a
oublié dans dans beaucoup d'entreprises
et ce soutien professionnel il est
extrêmement précieux pour faire grandir
les les compétences et puis dernier
dernier
le levier qui me paraît majeur c'est
d'organiser la montée en compétences la
montée en compétence des managers qui
sont aujourd'hui un peu délaissé j'ai
dit tout à l'heure ce que je pensais de
la formation au management telle qu'elle
est organisée en france
elle oublie les aspects collectifs c'est
à dire qu'elle voit le manager comme
c'est le reproche que françois dupuis a
dressé toujours tout à l'heure où au
leadership dans le management n'est pas
individuel par définition le management
c'est une approche collective et ne
pourront être de bons managers que ceux
qui manifestent de l'intérêt pour
l'autre qu'ils sont capables de faire
preuve d'empathie d' écoute et kiki qui
sont capables de le faire grandir ses
compétences c'est soft skills comment
comme on dit maintenant en bon français
voilà c'est les cinq leviers et pour
terminer je voulais venir sur la
définition à moi du management françois
dupuis a donné la sienne que qui
m'interpelle que je trouve intéressante
donc moi j'ai toujours eu beaucoup de
mal à trouver une définition et joe
style entre définition là d'autres deux
définitions la pire et la moins bonne
alors la pire je vous la donne c'est une
blague une blague sur qu'est-ce qu'un
cadre
si vous regarder dans le dictionnaire un
cadre c'est une structure rigide avec du
vide au milieu
voilà donc c'est la définition des
câbles donc si on en reste là on n'aura
pas beaucoup progressé
alors si on va vers une définition un
peu plus humaniste de plus intéressante
moi j'ai fait un gros projet avec mon
ami philippe détrie quand on a créé la
maison du management au sein du conseil
scientifique de la maison du management
on a fait une réflexion sur voilà qu'est
ce que c'est que le le management et
quel est le management qu'on veut
pousser en avant
valoriser et donc on a fait plusieurs
réunions d audition m'a fait parler des
dirigeants des salariés des
syndicalistes
et puis on est arrivé à cette définition
qui nous l'a acquis à chignin pardon qui
a fini par nous satisfaire donc je je
vous la propose le management des hommes
parce que pour nous il n'y a pas
d'autres management que celui des hommes
le mage main d oeuvre l art c'est un art
c'est pas une science c'est pas
discipline c'est un an
la d'animer une équipe pour atteindre
l'objectif et faire progresser chacun
voilà animer une équipe atteindre un
objectif et faire progresser chacun sait
les 3 me semble-t-il et les trois
objectifs qui donne de la vitalité qui
donne du coeur au management est le
troisième volet faire progresser chacun
est malheureusement très souvent oubliée
dans deux ans voilà donc je je vous
laisse dans le doute existentiel entre
la première définition celle du cadre et
la deuxième salle du management à vous
de choisir
[Musique]